you're on ox and you have to queue up
three songs what songs are you killing
oh Bob Marley One Love DJ Khaled God did
Rick Ross every day I'm hustling you're
saying you know we out here hustling you
know we gotta represent God and then we
gotta be one love at all time who would
you bet on in the fight you know what I
learned sometimes you should mind your
business God bless them hopefully y'all
have a good time and y'all figure it out
and let's just spread love man that's
all I'm about I don't want to get
involved in all that not me I like golf
I'm just chilling man I ain't into all
that you could switch places with one
person at this event who would it be and
why I love what God did with me I'm
saying it's important um to be yourself
so I feel like everybody should be happy
about themselves taking over the world
DJ cow is working on new music shout out
to Taylor Swift and everybody I say we
taking over the world that's a better
message I feel it should be weed taking
over the world